ils vous envoient un cv si vous dit quoi
pour restituer quand même ça faisait
deux ans qu'on se parle et suite à
l'émission régulièrement donc contacté
depuis juste une ou deux semaines mais
moi ça faisait deux ans qu'on se parler
de tout et de rien de ses tournages de
l'après émission de son livre mais
envoyer des photos de ses enfants de ses
projets il m'a parlé du fait qu'ils vont
alimenter une association école pour des
enfants jamais été ambiguë pendant sept
ans les deux pendant les deux ans j'ai
en tout cas moi j'ai rien vu et même à
ce que les messages facebook depuis son
supprimer la supprimer son compte donc
on peut pas voir sa version on voit que
mes messages à moi j'ai moi j'ai pas vu
d'ambiguïté ou au pire je me suis dis
bah c'est un quinquagénaire qui voilà
qui se prétend s'exprimer
vous trouvez ça vous le trouviez sympa
et actionnables avec vous l édile est
marrant c'est lui qui m'a retrouvé sur
facebook suite au tournage il a trouvé
mon nom et mon prénom et m'a dit j'ai
adoré jouer avec toi c'est super gardons
contact j'ai pas vu de preuve alors ça
vous êtes donc une ancienne candidate
des 12 coups de midi
et donc il vous envoyer des photos de
son sexe on vous explique ce qui s'est
passé avec emeline et elle nous donnera
son témoignage juste après regarder un
petit récapitulatif et on va revoir
d'autres extraits de 70 minutes
il y avait encore deux extraits qui
était assez édifiant et c'est fou que ce
soit toujours les mêmes messages
vous allez nous raconter tout ça
regardez ce parti décidément à chaque
jour son lot de révélations autour de la
sphère quesada depuis la mise en
détention provisoire de christian
quesada cet ancien champion du jeu les
12 coups de midi pour détention de
milliers d'imagés à caractère pédophile
sur son ordinateur les éléments contre
lui s'accumulent de jour en jour
aujourd'hui ces thèmes ligne une
ancienne candidate qui a rencontré
l'homme sur le plateau de l'émission
lors de sa participation en 2016
qui raconte comment il s'est retrouvé à
lui envoyer des photos de son pénis via
des messages privés sur les réseaux
sociaux après sa participation au jeu du
midi de tf1 christian quesada avait
retrouvé la jeune femme sur les réseaux
sociaux et avait entrepris avec elle une
discussion par message privé si pendant
plusieurs mois cette conversation était
tout à fait courtoise et amicale cela
n'a pas duré
alors qu'il racontait à emeline un
accident qu'il aurait subies en glissant
sur une plaque de verglas
le champion de midi aurait envoyé à la
jeune femme un message pour le moins
étrange pour l'informer qu'il s'était
ouvert le front mais pas seulement
j'ai bêtement glissé sur du verglas je
me suis ouvert le front est dans la
chute je me suis tordu le zizi une
information pour le moins étonnante
suite à laquelle il a cru bon d'envoyer
3 photo de son sexe à la jeune femme ce
soir emeline et sur le plateau de thé
pmp pour témoigner en exclusivité de
cette affaire qui vient encore un peu
plus lever le voile sur la vraie
personnalité de christian quesada
alors oui franchement je vous dis c'est
incroyable ce scénario alors emeline
vous racontez nous donc vous êtes chargé
d'affaires dans une entreprise de
câblage filaire donc vous l'aviez
affronter dans les douze coups de minuit
comme on l'a dit vous avez 26 ans vous
êtes allés jusqu'au duel en plus en 2016
face à christian vous entreteniez donc
comme vous nous l'avez dit une relation
amicale pendant deux ans où il était
assez cool voilà il faisait partager
plein de choses et christian qui sada
vous a ensuite envoyé des photos de son
sexe comment s'est passé parce que c'est
vrai que pour aussi c'est pareil c'est
le même scénario il disait quoi à fin
janvier 2018 donc premier message coucou
sabawi les toits il me dit ben moi je me
suis pas louper j'ai glissé sur une
plaque de verglas je me suis ouvert le
front j'ai sept points de suture et je
me suis dans ma chute tordu l'isi donc
oui voilà quelques mots près c'est ça et
donc moi j'ai répondu tout bêtement
ouhlala tu t'es pas louper voilà sacré
cascades je voulais me lance pas j'avais
passé oui c'est ça les captures des
fichiers pas trop qu'on dit sur le coup
du zizi je suis bon bah voilà c'est
christian ils parlent de tout il parle
de ça comme il se serait cassé le bras
il n'a pas de filtre d'accord ne sera
pas la télé c'est quelqu'un normale
entre guillemets mais deux fois moins
qu'attendu l'isi ça vous a pas
ouais j'ai déjà je suis mais comment on
peut ce soir le zizi et effet pas
positif voilà justement tu aurais bien
pour avoir ton avis mais tu risques de
te moquer aussi donc là j'avais un peu
peur je suis mais de quoi il parle de
visite de socatri sens du coup dans le
doute j'ai quand même dit que j'étais
pas moins que c'est que mon avis n'était
pas nécessaire vu qu'ils m'avaient dit
un peu avant quand même que il est élu à
l'hôpital donka oui sa loi comme en
commande avoué
emina programme d'anti douleurs et donc
ouais et donc voit pas ce que tu as fait
ça faisait deux ans qu'on se parle et
vraiment c'est pendant mais là il ya un
moment que l'ipad c'est chelou quand
même cette conversation
ouais voilà donc là on a voilà il ya pas
malveillant dû quand même
et là ils t'envoient une photo de son
zizi voilà c'est ça et là je me suis
même dit non c'est pas lui du coup c'est
quelqu'un qui favoriserait certes pas en
avant il avait quand même dit que soit
on facebook s'était fait pirater et
qu'il avait c'était pas lui qui
demandait des photos de jeunes filles
seins nus il avait dit ça donc je sais
pas encore vrai ou pas donc moi ça ça
m'intéresse c'est dans la tête parce
qu'il en avait pas rit madior je me suis
fait pirater mais facebook du coup
maintenant vaut mieux qu'on parle sur
twitter hockey chez et dans celui un
petit doute donc j'ai continué apparaît
en me disant je vais reconnaître sa voix
là son phrasé sa valeur de parler voir
si c'est bien lui auquel cas le prévenir
qu'il s'est fait mais les ratés alors
qu'ils n'ont emeline comment il est donc
en coulisse christian aghroum ce que
vous l'avez coteaux l'hyper zen
tu as l'air sympa voilà moi j'ai mangé
avec lui parce que c'était l'heure du
repas quand moi j'ai fait le tournage
donc aucun geste ambigu et il n'a pas
essayé n'ont d'autre voilà non et dans
la production personne n'était ou à la
direction quand je me suis fait
maquiller et coiffer
il y avait une maquilleuse qui avait dit
que les mets pas trop mais elle voulait
pas dire pourquoi elle avait dit je
chacun à doit avoir son avis on a tous
nos petits chouchous dans les maîtres
moi je n'aime pas d'accord mais après
voilà ça veut tout et rien dire c'est
une question de feeling je me suis
inquiété il vous posez des sur vous et
vous faisait des compliments il était
non mais surtout complimenter voilà sûr
sûrement savoir ce que je pense qu'il
pensait que j'étais plus jeune il avait
demandé lors de l'émission ça a été
diffusé à quel âge avait ce que quand
choses se retourner à ma place il a
voulu faire une aparté vraiment me
remercier de dire qu'il avait apprécié
jouer contre moi et 18 ans il a demandé
l'âge que j'avais donc de la verdict il
avait 26 ans à l'époque et la dia
d'accord d'accord voilà mais pas puisque
sa fin les peules j'ai pas vu demain on
va revenir sur avec mina sur d'autres
choses oui cudi emeline est très
intéressant sur la personnalité parce
qu'effectivement c'est ce que d'autres
ont commencé à dire aussi c'est vraiment
docteur jekyll et mr hyde ce à dire
qu'il avait garée un côté sympathique
débonnaire quelqu'un effectivement qui a
déjeuné avec lui m'a dit mais il était
affable un peu réservé mais affable et
puis avait ce côté
derrière l'écran et où derrière les
réseaux sociaux pervers ou en tout cas
extrêmement dangereux le rappel de sur
la présomption d'innonce olumes en effet
dire à chaque fois
alors on va voir un autre extrait après
un mini bain noir aux vins a compté une
chose suite à la sphère de nombreux
jeunes filles parfois mineurs affirme
avoir déjà reçu des messages douteux de
la part de questions quesada et j'ai une
question à vous poser juste après les
mines royal plusieurs jeunes filles dont
des mineures nous ont contactés et
transmis ses messages avec les mêmes
photos qu'elle aurait reçu 200 comptes
twitter des photos et des mots souvent
très crues j'ai envie de te câliner et
j'ai envie de te voir toute nue waouh tu
crois pas que tu vas un peu loin
christian là je t'envoie une vraie photo
de mon zizi pour te prouver ma confiance
nous avons choisi de ne pas vous lire
d'autres messages plus scabreuses encore
alors et c'est fou je vous le dis en
direct on m'envoie une capture d'écran
non une personne de la production de
chez nous qui a reçu exactement le même
sms que vous allez pas pareil non voilà
je suis désolé 1 voilà genre voilà je ne
vais pas bien
merci beaucoup je suis tombé et je me
suis ouvert le front est tordue de zz
mais bon c'est pas marrant mais bon du
coup quelques moqueries et c'est pas top
c'est vrai voilà et voilà mais je suis
désolé pour vous j'espère que ça ira
mieux
voilà mais c'est vraiment un prédateur
qui avait 900 me dire qu'il y avait un
système qui était mise en place de la
façon d'un batteur et jeunes filles et
de leur dire les choses est de pouvoir
arriver à la fin comme les mêmes traits
sacré look étonnant c'est une femme
s'est tendue c'est une phase où ils ont
fait un vrai si on voit ça voilà et
s'était mise en oeuvre de 9 à 12 que
j'embrasse ford ayant ses incroyables et
c'est exactement le même les mêmes sms
que vous est-ce que vous avez contacté
d'autres personnes voilà et d'autres
victimes ou pas du tout c'est été
contacté un petit peu sur twitter par
d'autres d'autres victimes qui ont eu le
même scénario ou presque voilà ça c'est
pas le verglas est ce que les services
de police nous ont contactés n'ont va
pas encore alors moi fait sage et la
plongée pas encore porté plainte parce
que je ne sais même pas si on peut
porter plainte et fort de choses et
c'est absolument c'est assimilé à une
agression sexuelle et des fourmis
parce que je peux pas à porter plainte
pour moi je portais pas pour les jeunes
filles qui n'ont plus la preuve parce
qu'elles vont supprimer 2 le peur de
voilà deux pour bloquer ça et je veux
apporter mois mais preuve au dossier de
manière collective s'il ya besoin pour
faire vraiment plus de poids parce qu'on
va parler de son problème avec les
enfants c'est archi grâce même encore
plus grave
à mes yeux les enfants les viols et
autres sur des enfants mais ici ce cache
parce qu'il est quand même très
intelligente même s'il est malade il a
déjà avoué pouvoir faire baisser sa
peine il connaît le système il va
ressortir
moi je veux qu'on cherche pour autre
chose n'est pas juste qu'on dise il est
malade il est pas enfin il est même pas
responsable on est qu'ils seront
capables peut-être de dire qu'il n'était
pas responsable de ses actes entre un
enfant et une jeune fille on est déjà
ces deux pathologies différentes
est-ce que vous avez ce que vous avez
coupé les ponts avec lui après total à
près de 7 épisodes pas totalement
totalement
il ya eu un malaise oui la seule et ça
me rassure pas c'est donc après les
redescendu évidemment les choses je le
dis à personne dans ma famille là il ya
des gens qui vont le découvrir ce soir
oui enfin je suis à la télé c'est
difficile à porter depuis je me suis
pris beaucoup de messages de personnes
qui pensent que je fais ça pour du buzz
non parce que le buzz il est déjà fait
pour l'argent non je viens ici
voilà c'est pas du tout pour quoi que ce
soit c'est dans son dos les supports des
jeunes femmes non j'ai pas d'enfants
mais je suis ta ta de sept neveux nièces
des générations qui sont beaucoup sur
les smartphones les beaux soirs mais mes
nièces sont fiers du parcours que j'ai
fait et voilà j'ai fait les douze
comédie j'ai été con christian elle
aurait été capable de le suivre sa bonne
on sort heureusement à lembras twitter
mais je sais qu'elle l'aurait fait parce
qu'elles ont confiance en moi et ça
serait dit à cette personne et elle
aurait peur cela est là j'aurais été
très mal et c'est pour tout ça et même
derrière je leur ai pas encore parlé
mais je vais leur parler de ça
finalement ne pas faire confiance du
tout sur les réseaux même si la personne
elle passe à la télé je vois pas la
raison
on est dans l'urgence sur les raisons de
la bonne affaire similaire à nous alors
vous avez participé donc aux 12 coups de
midi vous êtes viré de questions et
c'est vrai que voilà comme vous l'avez
dit vonier c'est votre petit essai
regard de teint pour c'était une énorme
star c'est un programme il ya cette
somme est trop 2010 le bleu voilà des
gens d'ici nous vous en parler c'est ça
mais puis moi derrière oui il ya eu un
bravo t'as été con question c'est pas
rien et puis vie derrière qui est venu
me chercher sur internet
en fait été flatté continuez vous
cherchez à oui c'est très flatteur au
lieu dit à l'antenne hors antenne il ya
me confirmer que de tous les il a vu
beaucoup de participants et que je sors
du lot c'est bien ça fait toujours
plaisir à entendre c'est vrai et après
que puisse écouter quelqu'un de normal
donc ça restait une conversation normale
de dire comment comment comment prix là
il a parce qu'après vous lui répondez
plus comment il a rattrapé le coup après
sur l'essai mais qui n'a rien attraper
c'est à dire que le lendemain aux farges
payen lendemain mais on va dire deux
semaines plus tard coco comment vas tu
as et sur l'avant je répète je répondais
dans l'eure j'avais à chaque fois je
m'étais une semaine à répondre en fait
je vais attendre et voir si relancer ces
têtes sur l'île à recommencer ou pas du
tout du tout
rien aucune allusion et c'est rien du
tout et c'est ça qui est devenue ma les
ans et un jour il a montré ses photos de
sexes et puis après rien mais si de rien
n'était 2 voilà c'est comment vas-tu moi
je suis en vacances moi je vends ta il
en est là tout ça va commencer à mettre
un peu la pucelle
la thaïlande mais c'était aussi la
thaïlande mais c'est bien ça je me suis
dit mais non ce qui fait en thaïlande on
connaît le pays comme quoi la c1 c'est
le tourisme sexuel donc pas que ça mais
bon au 0 tout ce qui va nous dire on va
dire c'est me voyais pas aller à la
police d'evreux celui d'evreux pour dire
j'ai un dossier sur beaux-arts ça mais
jean pierre g us ouakam et moi là quand
j'ai su ça j'ai pu enfin je me suis dit
oh non ce fin j'ai pensé à son image
puisque à la mienne en fait ouais je me
suis je me suis montré mon nom mon
prénom j'ai rien à cacher du coup
derrière j'ai eu beaucoup de messages
aussi haineux et c'est pas grave ça je
suis de couper le téléphone et il se
passe plus rien en fait ça je suis plus
forte que ça j'en avais je pense qu'il
ya des personnes qui pourraient je pense
même qu'il est peut-être passé à l'acte
parce que moi il m'a proposé de venir
chez lui ah oui mais il me l'a proposé
de manière sympathique j'en serais sympa
qu'on parle de l'émission concevoir
adoré des jeux je pense que c'était plus
facile est vu comme il a pu être lourd
par message qu'est ce qu'il a pu faire
physiquement et il ya peut-être des
victimes qui n'osent pas parler me
semble que c'est primordial dans le
témoignage des mines c'est qu'elle n'a
pas osé porter plainte
il faut aller porter plainte exacte cela
il faut aller dire aux médias du
cyberharcèlement il ya quelqu'un qui
vous envoie des photos il a probablement
envoyer des voies ferrées l'époque c'est
pour ça c'est pas à vous de dire si vous
vous sentez harcelés ou pas il a pas
vous envoyer ça il a pas je trouve que
c'est quand même ils auraient je pense
que ça ne c'est cette affaire était pour
ça que le reportage était intéressant me
semble-t-il aussi c'est qu'il doit
servir aussi de jurisprudence pour
toutes les jeunes filles et les jeunes
garçons qui peuvent être harcelé sur les
réseaux sociaux à qui on envoie des
photos qui inconvenante et je pense que
ça doit aussi servir de leçon pour
beaucoup en est alors une ligne juste
après donc est-ce que vous appréciez
photo est ce que vous avez été
traumatisée ce que vous en avez parlé
donc nous aider à travers 100 personnes
personnes c'est quand personne sayan en
personne et vous avez gardé quand même
on avait gardé quand même la
conversation dans votre portable n'avait
pas eu facile je regardais moi je suis
quelqu'un je supprime rien je blochérien
ce qu'on m'a dit pourquoi tu as pas
bloquer si j'avais mieux servir j'ai
déjà arrivé donc ça sert à quoi c'est
déjà arrivé
vous avez gardé cette photo quelqu'un je
suis très preuve je suis
on vous a dit au moins j'ai une preuve
vous ne savez pas que moi en faire à ce
moment là mais je suis dit c'est pas
anodin
je n'avais pas parlé à personne 3 c'est
la chose apparaît ça paraît fou même si
j'en ai parlé à mes parents et il aurait
était démuni mon rib a faim il n'aurait
pas trop sur ça ne m'a pas une copie
s'il aurait été déçu en fait j'étais à
l'époque où je voulais pas que les gens
soient déçus de l'image qui l'avez vous
avez pour ça que si on voulait un
président mal à un niveau bas parce qu'à
l'époque il a eu beaucoup de hauteur sur
le fait qu'il était souriant prétentieux
cédant il ya beaucoup de choses de dites
sur lui et j'étais une de ses premières
[Musique]
sur internet à terme est arrêté il est
sympathique et tout moi je me suis pris
une double claque en fait je me suis dit
mais vous allez vite vous aviez peur de
la mairie fondu et c'est difficile de
tout ce temps de l'acceptation au fait
que c'est pas du tout la personne que je
pensais être je pensais être la seule à
avoir reçu ces images qui m'a dit si tu
en parles je serai d'où ça vient il est
vrai tout le monde d'accord et donc en
face à ce qu'aucun on avait parlé mais
il n'aurait jamais su il aurait jamais
su d'où sagnier parce qu'il est envoyé à
des biens sur zentiva par isaac et c'est
facile de dire après coup on aurait dû
être audible comment ça se fait on
aurait dû savoir on aurait peu de vous
même vous avez posé plein de gens n'ont
pas osé donc on va savourer ce quelqu'un
voilà de média tu manges et a mené les
policiers au savoir ce qu'il faut faire
dans des cas comme ça et malheureusement
il faut se déplacer aller porter plainte
et je trouve ça dommage
notons qu'aujourd'hui on devrait faire
un numéro vert ou quelque chose de
beaucoup plus pratique pour pouvoir
signaler très rapidement oui même s'il
ya une démarche quand même mis trop
compliqué aujourd'hui dès qu'on ait
heurté pas une image province a alors
tiens les journalistes ont tenté de
comprendre comment christian kisan at il
pu avoir ce comportement
voici la réponse d'une psychologue
spécialiste des pulsions pédophiles
regardez le succès peut monter à la tête
en la personne et plus justement avant
elle a souffert de solitude
brimades d'isolement d'humiliation juste
de rejet de la part des autres plus
lorsqu'elle accède à la notoriété
le contraste fait qu'elle se sent
maintenant dans un sentiment peut-être
de toute puissance et encore et du coup
d'impunité c'est à dire je peux faire
tout ce que je veux on n'arrêtera pas je
suis quelque part au dessus des lois je
suis au dessus des règles
alors voilà donc c'était 66 minutes hier
alors emeline déjà merci d'être avec
nous parce qu'il ya un autre il ya
d'autres infos qui sont tombés on a
parlé de jean luc reichmann vendredi il
a inauguré avec chris marquès la foire
du trône à paris
et pour l'occasion on a appris qu'un
dispositif spécial a été mise en place
pour que jean luc reichmann ne soient
pas interrogés sur la sphère quesada par
les journalistes qui couvraient
l'événement voilà les représentants de
la foire de paris affirme avoir reçu des
consignes jean luc reichmann il
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il en souffre
beaucoup de cette affaire est ce que
vous avez eu des nouvelles il vous en a
parlé par pas encore on n'avait pas eu
au téléphone
non pas du tout d'accord alors depuis
la sphère quesada la production va
prendre certaines mesures pour éviter un
nouveau scandale
la production des douze coups de midi
affirme réfléchir à d'autres règles doré
de recrutement elle pourrait demander au
futur candidat
une attestation sur l'honneur et il ya
une rumeur qui inaugure sur le fait que
la production
alors peut-être qu'il fallait pas tout
mais d'abord de le premier cas c'est que
même s'il avait su dans le détail
imaginé d'abord laissé savoir que les
émissions seraient par 4 5 par jour note
is a good avance et légalement c'est
vrai que quelqu'un qui a été condamné
quatre projets sa peine il est paraît il
voit là il est possible que tu as un
passé trouble
quoique qu'on doit de sortir du jeu
après évidemment moi j'ai quand même
l'impression vu ce que vous racontez et
c'est peut-être un cap qui est pas
unique adaptait des dizaines voire des
centaines
donc c'est totalement impossible quand
on passe six mois à l'antenne
tu n'es pas une personne c'est ce qu'un
avocat un juge une victime qui est pas
juste prison tel est ton téléphone pour
dire écoutez le monsieur qui a la télé a
de gros problèmes moi on est mois déjà
moi perso je n'y crois pas du tout quand
on voit maintenant quand même le système
qui consiste à aller alors moi je moi je
crois en moi je suis tout fait pour moi
c'est impossible je vous le dis moi je
pense que à l'ap moi moi personnellement
je pense que la production n'était pas
au courant du convoi est minime